[Music]
today we're checking out Intel's Ark
b570 for the first time which as the
name suggests is a cut down version of
the
b580 now the b580 really impressed me a
month ago when I first reviewed it but
unfortunately since then things have SED
a bit first and foremost as I said we're
now a month out from that release and
unfortunately you still can't buy an ark
b580 graphics card so that sucks and
I'll talk more about this later on in
the review the other major issue was the
discovery that the b580 has a major
overhead issue that sees performance
suffer in CPU demanding games especially
when using an older or slower CPU now
I've already dedicated a few content
pieces to investigating this issue and
today's review will be using updated
data to evaluate the
b570 As for the b570 this model is meant
to cost $220 us so $30 less than the
b580 it's based on the same 272 s mm die
but the XE core count has been reduced
by 10% from 20 to 18 the peak core clock
has also been reduced by 4% from 2,850
MHz to
2,750 MHz the memory subsystem has been
downgraded to a 160 bit wide bus Which
sees the vram buffer reduced to 10 GB
and despite using the same 19 GBS per
second memory the memory bandwidth has
has been reduced by 177% to 380 GB per
second so in a nutshell we're looking at
a 10% reduction in cause 4% frequency
downgrade 20% less vram and 17% less
memory bandwidth all of this for just a
12% saving which might put the b570 in a
bit of a tough spot but of course we'll
have to look at the performance so let's
go do that first up we have Marvel
Rivals and here the b570 roughly matched
the performance of the RTX 4060 at a
1440p with 60 FPS making it 12% slower
than the b580 and 25% faster than the RX
7600 switching to the ryzen 55600 still
saw the b570 coming 11% slower than the
b580 but now it's also 8% slower than
the RTX 460 and just 10% faster than the
7600 then if we enable upscaling using
the 5600 we see that performance is
fairly similar across the board though
the b570 is now the slowest GPU tested
rendering 882 FPS making it 7% slower
than the RX
7600 next up we have Star Wars Jedi
Survivor and at Native 1440p the b570
was 14% slower than the b580 using
either the 9800 x3d or
5600 and this placed it on par with the
RTX 460 and RX
7600 But when we enable upscaling it
ends up 9% slower than the b580 and 8%
slower than the radon and G Force
gpus now Spider-Man remastered has
proven to be extremely problematic for
the arc gpus when paired with a lower in
CPU and the b570 further demonstrates
the overhead issue when paired with the
9800 x3d at the native 1440p resolution
the b570 is 12% slower than the b580 and
more crucially is faster than both the
RTX 4060 and RX 7600 27% faster in the
case of the radon GPU
however when we switch over to the ryzen
55600 the b570 is now just 4% slower
than the b580 which seems good but it's
not that good because performance of the
arc gpus is limited to around 80 FPS due
to the additional CPU overhead and this
is bad because it means whereas the b570
was 27% faster than the RX 7600 went
paired with the 9800 x3d it's now 5%
slower using the ryzen 5 Pro processor
and not only that but when enabling
upscaling the b570 ends up 23% slower
than the RX 7600 as performance is again
capped to around 80 FPS when using the
slower ryzen 5
processor the Hogwarts Legacy results
are interesting firstly at Native 1440p
using the 9800 x3d the b570 is 16%
slower than the b580 making it the
slowest GPU tested switching to the to
the 5600 reduces that margin to 9% and
now the b570 is able to match the RTX
460 then once we enable up scaling The
Arc GPU gets left behind and quite
interestingly this is also an issue when
using a very popular CPU such as the
9800 x3d in fact with the 9800 x3d the
b570 ends up being almost 30% slower
than the RX
7600 next up we have Space Marine 2 and
here the b570 is quite a bit slower than
the b580 18% at 1440p when using the
9800 x3d though that margin does come
down to 12% when paired with the
5600 the bigger issue is seen when
enabling upscaling as the arc gpus are
limited to less than 60 FPS when using a
more mid-range CPU and in fact the issue
is still quite bad even with the 9800
x3d at Native 1440p when pair with the
5600 the b570 is 20% slower than the RX
7600 which is bad and things don't
improve with upscaling as the margin
extends only slightly to
22% that said the rad on gpus have their
own overhead issue in this example so a
less favorable matchup would be with the
RTX 4060 which ends up being almost 50%
faster than the
b570 now the arc CPU overhead issue
wasn't a problem in a plague Tower
requium and here we see that the b570
ends up 11% slower than the b580 at
Native 1440p using either CPU then with
upscaling enabled the b570 is able to
match the RX 7600 so decent performance
overall moving on to cyberp punk 2077 we
see that the b570 is roughly equivalent
to that of the RTX 460 in this title
making it a few frames faster than the
RX 7600 at least when using the 9800x 3D
installing the ryzen 5 processor sees
performance become more CPU limited as
you'd expect and as a result All 4 gpus
are now delivering similar performance
at around 60 FPS however if we enable
upscaling this pushes all four CPUs to
around 80 to 84 FPS but what you'll
notice here is that the 1% lows are
considerably lower when using an arc GPU
Dying Light to like a plague tail
requium is a game where the arc overhead
issue wasn't so much of an issue and
that being the case the b570 performs
very well in this title even with the
5600 and even even when using upscaling
for example the 5600 upscaling data saw
the b570 roughly match the RTX 460
making it just 4% slower than the
GeForce
GPU moving on to Starfield and like the
b580 the b570 performs quite poorly in
this title rendering just 37 FPS at
Native
1440p and this is when using the medium
quality preset the same level of
performance is seen with both the 9800
x3d and 5600 but when we enable
upscaling The Arc gpu's cap out at
around 50 FPS when using the ryzen 5
processor whereas the RTX 4060 goes on
to render 63 FPS making the GeForce GPU
a massive 31% faster than the
b570 the Dragon Age performance is a bit
odd both the b570 and b580 are capped at
67 FPS using either the 9800 x3d or 5600
and this is the same level of
performance seen from the RTX
4060 then when we enable upscaling The
Arc gpus push up to just over 80 FPS
whereas the RTX 4060 ends up around 6%
faster Star Wars Outlaws is an extremely
demanding game even when using the
medium preset and as a result the b570
was good for just 37 FPS at 1440p or 53
FPS with upscaling enabled interestingly
we saw slightly better performance using
the 5600
though we're only talking about a few
extra
frames the problem here for the b570
being that whereas it match the RTX 460
at 40 and 40p when using the 5600 if we
go and enable upscaling it ends up being
133% slower as the arc GPU struggle and
really fail to reach 60
FPS testing with War Thunder using the
default direct X11 mode provid some
interesting results firstly using the
9800 x3d at native1 440p we see that the
b570 is actually faster than the RTX 460
10% faster in fact but when we switch to
the 5600 the b570 ends up 20% slower as
both Arc gpus are capped at around 180
FPS and the margins only get worse when
you enable
upscaling but if we go and change to the
direct X12 API while everything else
changes firstly using the 9800x 3D the
b570 is just 6% % slower than the b580
though it's also 8% slower than the RTX
460 but then if we switch to the ryzen 5
processor things again look much the
same though enabling upscaling does hand
the RTX 4060 a slight performance
Advantage essentially though the direct
X12 API solves arc's overhead issue in
this title the last game tested is The
Last of Us Part One and here the b570
match the RTX 460 and RX 7600 at 1440p
when paired with the 9800 x3d
and we saw much the same use in the
ryzen 5 processor The Arc gpus did fall
behind a little with upscaling enabled
but even so the b570 is performance
remained
respectable finally here's a quick look
at power consumption and here the b570
is fine consuming anywhere from 8 to 14%
less power than the b580 which makes
sense given the downgrades generally
power consumption is around 20 WTS
higher than that of the RTX 460 so again
power consumption really isn't an issue
and it's not something Gamers will be
concerned with when buying this
particular
GPU okay so on average using the 9800
x3d at 1440p the b570 was 133% slower
than the b580 and therefore roughly
matched the RTX 4060 and RX 7600 so a
pretty solid result there for a $220 us
GPU but when enabling upscaling for
greater performance the b570 slips a
little and is now slightly slower than
the RX7 600 still not bad performance
overall though but if you have a slower
CPU such as the ryzen 5 5600 the b570 it
does okay at Native 40 and 40p again
matching the RX 7600 while it was just
8% slower than the b580 then with
upscaling enabled it was 4% slower than
the RX 7600 and 6% slower than the b580
so again decent performance overall for
what is meant to be a $220 us GPU but
before we go and make any value calls
let's check out the cost per Frame data
okay so a couple of things before we go
over the cost per Frame data firstly I'm
well aware that you can't actually buy a
b580 for $250 and retailers such as new
Ager out of stock so as it stands the
$250 us MSRP for that part it's not
really a thing even a month out since
that release that said listing scalper
prices here not particularly useful
either so essentially if you can't get a
B5 8 for $250 us or the equivalent price
in your region then just don't buy it
the same applies to the new
b570 didn't knock the box over we're all
good uh yeah same applies to the b570
availability there it's probably going
to be horrible as well of course I don't
know yet because we're reviewing these
ahead of the public
release but unless you can get a b58 for
the MSRP it won't be worth buying of
course wait till my conclusion before I
get to the whether I'm going to
recommend this thing or not but I just
want to give that disclaimer before
going over the following graphs it's
also really difficult to accurately
assess the value of the new arc gpus as
it depends on quite a few different
factors firstly there's the vram thing
to consider both the b580 and b570 offer
more vrm than competing AMD and Nvidia
Parts but then there's also the overhead
issue which often sees the arc gpus
underperform at 1080P and even at 1440p
with upscaling and the CPU plays a key
role in all of this so that being the
case I have a few different data sets
that we're going to go over to evaluate
the value of the b570 so let's get into
it okay so at Native 1440p the value of
the b570 looks pretty great especially
when used in the 9800 x3d here it
matches the value of the b580 making it
15% better value than the RX 7600 and
34% better value than the RTX
460 now if we look at the data recorded
with the ryzen 55600 the b570 improves
its position relative to the b580 now
coming in 4% better value but when
compared to the RX 7600 it's now
offering just 12% better value though
it's still 22% better value than the RTX
460 but it's the upscaling data that is
far less favorable for Intel using the
9800 x3d the b570 is just 10% better
value than the radio on GPU and 18%
better value than the RTX 460 and it
gets even worse when using upscaling
with the ryzen 55600 is here the b570 is
just 8% better value per frame R
compared to the 7600 and if we were to
use the 1% low data this comparison
would be even less favorable for
Intel so as I said evaluating the value
of Intel's new arc battle mage gpus is
rather difficult on one hand if you have
a powerful enough CPU they're pretty
great but on the other hand How likely
are those shopping for a budget graphics
card to have a highend CPU think ryzen
57600 or better so that being the case
probably not very likely and then for
those of you with a CPU equal to or
perhaps even slower than the ryzen 55600
becomes a more difficult Choice going
with the rad on RX 7600 for example
that'll ensure your CPU lasts longer so
that'll maximize value there and you
should also receive better performance
overall pending a CPU upgrade of course
this is a major problem for the b570
because as an entry-level GPU ideally
intended for Budget gaming it really
needs to work well with CPUs that are
even older than the 5600 because let's
be real here the vast majority of budget
Gamers don't have a CPU that's more
powerful than a ryzen
55600 and as we just saw for those of
you with a CPU equal to the 5600 the
value of these new arc gpus often isn't
particularly great you're generally
saving very little and when you consider
the numerous compromises you'd be making
when going with an ark GPU it's hard to
argue that you end up saving that much
if anything at all I think the b580 is
still worth the gamble as the 12 GB vram
buffer makes it much more appealing than
the RX 7600 and RTX 460 but the cut down
b570 it just isn't cheap enough in my
opinion it needs to be $200 us at most
the 10 GB buffer is certainly better
than 8 but it's not that much better and
really moving forward 12 GB should be
the minimum for gpus priced at or above
$200 but in a world where the ark b570
is available for purchase at $220 us
should you buy it I think my answer to
that would be probably not as I said it
needs to cost no more than $200
otherwise I just recommend spending a
bit more going $250 for either the B5 80
or RX 7600 and since you can't get the
b580 I guess the radio and GPU is it and
this really has been the issue the big
issue for Ark not the drivers not the
CPU overhead but rather availability
we're now a month out from the b580
release and availability is extremely
scarce and worse still pricing in other
regions for these Arc gpus it hasn't
been nearly as impressive as what we've
seen over in the US for example here in
Australia you can actually buy a b580
right now you can pick one up but it's
going to cost you $470 Australian doar
and that's not scalable price is that's
just the regular going price for a b580
here in Australia and it's the same
price you will currently pay for an RTX
460 and it's about $40 more than an RX
7600 in fact if we go and put together
another cost per frame graph using the
more favorable 1440p native data so not
the upscaling data just the native data
and we go and use the local Australian
pricing Arc looks really poor in terms
of value the 9800 x3d data sees the b570
come in just 6% better value than the RX
7600 and then just 5% better value when
using the ryzen
55600 and this is all assuming that the
b570 ends up costing
$410 Australian which I've been told
might not be the case it might be more
like 430 to 400 $40 and if true that
will be a
disaster so a bit of a disappointing
story for Intel's latest Arc generation
and things started out so positive so
very exciting at the start uh only for a
number of critical things to go wrong
and while Intel could still save this
series that's yet to play out and for
now I'd really only recommend buying the
b580 at the MSRP so not necessarily the
b570 think at the MSRP the b580 still
makes sense for a lot of people but of
course getting it at that MSRP is nearly
impossible at this point in time and
then we have other regions like
Australia where the b580 needs to be at
least 20% cheaper than the RX 7600 or
RTX 460 otherwise you might as well just
get one of those competing Parts the
b570 on the other hand needs to be
cheaper again I think $200 us is the
most I can see that part being worth so
for now unfortunately that means it is
Dead on Arrival at least in my opinion
so not a great start to the new year but
fingers crossed things improve and buy a
lot and that's going to do it for this
video If you enjoyed this review of
Intel's Arc b570 I know it's not our
usual review format but given the
overhead issue and all that I thought
this data set with fewer gpus was
probably the way uh to evaluate the b570
so let me know what you think about in
the comment section below uh also just
let me know what you think about the
b570 in general do you think this needs
to be a cheaper product uh yeah give me
your thoughts
uh also we have patreon uh the join
button for YouTube either one of those
will give you access to our exclusive
Discord server we have monthly live
streams for members only behind the
scenes content Q&A stuff a lot of cool
things though so check that out if
you're interested but if not that's
perfectly fine and I would like to thank
you for watching this video I'm your
host daeve see you again next time
[Music]